so you had experience with ACTA Paris
and that was an inspiration for the film
and I want to ask about that but I also
want to ask about you too did did you
know anything about act of Paris before
you started the film was 9 in 92 so I
didn't know very much about act up I
remember that they did a very great
action on rubenesque de la Concorde they
put a ping condom on it so it was like
Familia 9 9 years old kid like wow what
is it but about the message about the
political aspects I didn't know anything
about it so how did you prepare out it
for you as well I had no idea
I'm Argentinian I grew up I grew up in
Argentina so no I I say that because I
was not in France so I can imagine that
maybe if I had been in France I would
have seen that the pink condom but no
well that's something to do bad I know
there were some associations in
Argentina like equivalent associations
but no act up I didn't so we read books
we had access to the audiovisual
archives from France so we could see
like all the news from that time in
which we would see the all the actions
that they were carrying out and then we
well I saw a film called Silverlake
you can French is view silver look you
silver like view which is a documentary
that is just like so raw and you can see
how how bad the sickness can can affect
your buddy it was a very good film to
understand how deep you can go and then
what else we had D Dearest had yeah the
book yeah and we had a conference with
Philippe marshal the casino list yeah do
you direct this type of preparation for
them or did you yes because you know I
was kind of searching what kind of you
know for instance I don't like to go to
through too much documents
I want to people to feel a little bit
free about reinventing this story even
if it was a little bit my story it's a
little bit historical but not that much
so I wanted them to be free but
you know I gave them the book of dizzy
Lestrade who was the first president of
actor Paris no because in France you
when you do an association like this you
have you have to have a president which
is different in in your country we are
very formal about that so I gave I gave
them the the book of digital Scott
because I wanted them to understand how
we were talking at this moment what
words we were using what kind of tone we
had when we were discussing and you know
because when I was really I didn't ask
them to imitate people of this period
weird people I told them that I wanted
to hear the voices during the debate
that I heard 25 years ago so the book of
detail is what was very interesting for
them because they knew what was the
topic the topics at the moment and the
way we were talking so that was more
mostly what I was searching for well I
think it's really interesting the film
like there's there's little introduction
into this world besides that very short
this is the first weekly meeting and
just described it and then so much of
the film is these meetings where you
really get a sense of just the the power
and the struggle that's going on there
and I was just what how did you how do
you approach those scenes because
filming a room of people talking could
cannot be as dynamic as it appears in
the film and wonder what the approach to
that was yes I was I was a little bit
afraid of that of course you know
because you are very brave when you
write a script and after when you have
to direct that you are a little bit
that's more difficult I think but it's
true that it was very important to me to
compare the the debate the power of
talking of the words with the actions
the the dancing scenes the sex scene I
wanted a very big difference between all
these dimensions we are so different and
so I I just I wanted you know all these
debates at the DMV theater
be like a brain with people connecting
to each other and creating visions like
actions like posters like new slogans in
contrast in the in those scenes the very
public meeting scenes there's also these
intimate sex scenes between the two of
you and I'm wondering how did you how
did you go about shooting that I had you
to develop your relationship on camera
to because it seems very intimate
throughout the film well the second
working session that we did when we were
auditioning
he asked just to be bare chest and just
lie down on a couch and just try to to
be together and improvise we had some
little dialogues that he invented for
that scene but then that was mainly an
improvisation so maybe the sex scene you
wrote did taking things from that
improvisation improvisation so I
remember that that was the first time
that we thought that it could be that it
was possible to build something together
right there's this chemistry that you
can really you know force or create you
just have to try it out and that was
that was a great day I remember I just
felt very comfortable with him and and
that allowed that seemed to exist in the
way it does yeah yeah yeah and we had
two real souls before the for the
shooting in underwear I'm not naked and
it helped us I think to be more relaxed
on the shooting yeah we found like this
like this kind of choreography that then
we could inhabit and we did it on the UM
the shooting yeah really at the end we
just we rehearse we did a lot of real
short during the shooting because it was
very hard to find the positions and
everything because it the two cameras
yeah yeah yes because you don't you know
they they are very generous with the
theme so they were they did all that for
me for the film but you know you cannot
ask them to do it like ten times and
that's not possible so that was more do
two times I think twice that No yeah
then we were doing some dialogues well
there was a whole day of working and it
was very good a lot so all this sweat
that you see in
we were sweating because we had lights
everywhere it's not that we were yes but
it works
I mean it's one day and it's like 12
minutes in the film we are arguing about
no but honestly the the technicians were
we're nervous yes yes that's right I try
to make that these kind of scene it's no
it's a normal scene you know that you
have to play a lot they have you know
because it's not I told them it was it
won't be of course pornographic so okay
and you take either it will be a little
bit I can I say
prude I don't know modest and so but
they knew but because of that that you
have to pay to play really the sex the
sex and at the same time you have a lot
of things going on in this scene it's
just not a sex scene it's not performing
I I don't I don't want these kind of sex
of sex in to be a performance I think
it's boring I think when you it's it's
for me it's a little bit I feel guilty
when I see sex scene on the field
because the people are looks so much
better than me in a bed and I think I'm
very dull I'm and doing a very stupid
things in the bar
I'm very tired of that there's a lot of
physicality in those scenes and also
obviously the dance scenes and and and
you you lose a lot of weight in the film
I did one yet I mean you go from being a
very vibrant alive person to someone
who's close to death I was working with
that what the experience was like
physically to his way but also like in
terms of filming when did you film those
see were they at the end of shooting in
general is that the problem it was all
in chronological order so we started
doing the film well I mean exactly in
the same order that you see the film
then we cut my hair and then at a
certain point I had to start to lose
weight but we were still shooting so
that was that the worst thing that I had
to you know try to keep some energy and
at the same time I cut carbs and I was
feeling weaker and weaker and weaker
so that was stuff for me no well but
then I did on the same at the same time
it was very useful for the film and it
facilitated a lot of things because we
were I was withdrawing from the group
and I don't know was seeing me weaker
and weaker so of course you know really
seem like striction and really start
mirroring each other in a in a good way
but I can tell you it was very tiring
and I was waiting for the final clap I
was very exhausted
of course like what do you think that
this film especially in the level of
hopelessness at that time but there
still was activism and working on
something there what do you think today
what it says about global activism or
being involved in any any type of
political movement is there a lesson at
all I I mean I didn't do the film this
film to give lessons to anyone really I
just try to make selfish things you know
but it's the very honest way of putting
it because what I can say is that it's
true that now in France and everywhere
in the world you have small groups
activists and there are not very popular
especially from by the politicians and I
just say that you know because the film
was a big success in France that's very
weird because we were not so popular at
the time and so maybe you should think a
little bit more about what is going on
politically in this kind of small minor
of groups because maybe it's something
very important that these groups are
saying to the society that's the main
thing for for me well I want to thank
you all for bringing the family being
here